moi je suis très inquiète je viens de
faire un déplacement dans le
Pas-de-Calais et j'ai des élus qui m'ont
dit que
au moment du Ramadan il y avait des
parents qui demandaient dans des écoles
primaires à ce que les enfants n'aillent
pas à la cantine et que on prenne en
charge la surveillance de ces enfants
puisqu'il n'était pas à la cantine ça
nécessitait d'une surveillance
supplémentaire
moi je ne veux pas de cette France là
moi je veux d'une école publique
parfaitement laïque où il n'y a pas de
Ramadan où il n'y a pas d'abaya où il
n'y a pas de signe
ostensibles religieux je veux que ce
lieu là par dessus tout soit préservé
pas besoin de changer la loi pour ça
alors après pour qu'il soit préservé il
faut être très clair sur les valeurs que
l'on porte moi tous mes enfants sont
dans l'école publique
c'est important pour moi mais parce que
je crois on les colle publique je crois
dans une école publique qui permet
justement à chacun d'avoir de ne pas
subir d'influence
et donc moi s'il fallait faire une loi
pour rappeler tout ça et faire en sorte
que nos enseignants et que les
directeurs d'établissement et nos mères
ne soient pas en difficulté face à ces
situations je n'hésiterai pas à voter
une telle loi mais en tout cas moi je
suis très inquiète et je ne veux pas que
la religion pénètre comme ça dans ses
espaces là